[Music]
in today's day I driven world computer
vision and AI at the edge of the heart
of everything from factory assembly
lines and retail inventory management to
urgent care medical equipment like
x-rays and cat-scans computer vision and
a gir even instrumental in pirating and
amusement parks shopping malls and
health care so if a GI the algorithms
are processed locally on a hardware
device without requiring an internet
connection
using data that's generated from the
device and processed to give real-time
insights often and less than a few
milliseconds you toss these new AGI for
IOT developers nanodegree program which
was developed in partnership with Intel
teaches fluency in some of the most
cutting-edge technologies it introduces
students to Intel's distribution of the
open video toolkit which allows
developers to deploy pre-trained deep
learning models through an optimized set
of inference engines based on
convolutional neural networks the
toolkit extends workloads across Intel's
hardware including accelerators and
maximizes performance graduates will be
able to accelerate the development and
deployment of high-performance computer
vision and deep learning solutions using
Intel's wide range of silicon and the
open vina toolkit this solace graduates
to maximize application performance
across a range of heterogeneous Intel
architectures to deliver fast efficient
deep learning workloads build and deploy
AI models at the edge sign up to you
Dusty's new AGI for IOT developers
nanodegree program today